- One, this is five.
- Oh, these are actually them.
So this is the bag?
It's fresh.
- Yeah.
- Is this an unboxing video?
(yelling)
You've got your perspective.
(electronic music)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(thoughtful music)
What's been the most,
knowing how closely you've followed me,
what's been the thing
that's most surprised you?
- I'd say the biggest
thing that's surprised me
is seeing how involved you are
in the content that comes out.
(laughing)
Which I know sounds crazy,
but I keep that in mind, 'cause I'm like,
you have so much other stuff going on,
yet you're doing all the copy.
You're doing the context.
You're doing it and so, I
was surprised to see that.
I knew you were involved,
but I figured it wasn't as deep as you are
and to see that
and also you're literally
communicating with us.
- Yeah, it's a really
interesting point, right?
Which is, Andy a lot of times talks about,
you need to talk more about being smart
or things of that nature,
because I don't talk about certain things,
everyone's just using,
it's not that people are cynical
or don't think I'm a real guy.
I think people are just using common sense
to think it's impossible,
because I don't think people realize
the level of speed that
I'm actually talking about.
It's a level of speed that most
people aren't accustomed to.
So then, you can't think it's true,
because you think you're going hard,
but you're also spending an
hour a day watching my content.
(yelling)
(laughing)
- I get it, I get it.
(hip hop music)
Gary Vee.
- Do you like that?
- I do.
- (mumbles).
- Yeah.
We can add more to it, I just don't know.
(hip hop music)
- Gary Vee.
Is it the same length as,
(popping mouth)
- It went a bit longer.
- Yeah, can you make it tighter?
- What do you want it to look like?
- As it goes, I want my signature.
Gary Vee.
All right, This is it?
- These are them.
These are one, this is five.
- Oh, these are actually them.
So this is the bag?
It's fresh.
Is this an unboxing video?
- [Man] Quick unboxing.
- This is it.
Man this is so fucking,
I can't believe this.
The video of like me
coming up with this idea in
San Francisco on the spot
to this moment right now
of the flippity flop.
Do we do something back here that's just,
like to me, one of the
things that would be,
for example like it's really interesting.
This just caught my eye right this second.
The thought that there would be something
that you could then slide something into
is really rad to me.
I wanna do something with,
if this gonna be something like five,
it's the biggest shoe I'm gonna make,
maybe ever for me,
just 'cause it's gonna
matter to me the most,
it's my hand gesture.
Back to weird stuff, what if we created
something that hasn't happened before.
It's really funny that it just sat here
love the idea.
- [Man] That would be sick.
- I think so.
- Is there a way to make
this more substantial?
- Like very substantial, yeah.
And then it comes in the
pack five little things here,
and then a month later something comes out
that's exclusive for $1.99 on K-Swiss
to put in there.
You see where I'm going?
- Yeah, I know exactly what you're saying.
Keep updating with this
every month or whatever.
- You know?
- It's pretty cool.
- I remember exactly
where we were sitting.
- You can be like choop-choop.
That's such a cool video.
This is fucking cool, man.
(somber music)
- [Man In Car] Gary V.
Keep up the good work man!
- Thank you, brother!
I love when people are like,
"Gary, you don't get it."
I fucking do get it, bro.
Explain to me why you shouldn't be living
on your own means.
Can somebody make a video that counters
my point to why parents should be quietly
paying or publicly paying
for their kids life?
The fucking comments I get on DM's when
this shit comes out is crazy!
They're like, "Gary, bro,
easy for you to say."
No, no, not easy for me to say.
I lived on my own two feet!
I fucking went further than that!
I fucking built a business for my parents!
Fuck you!
Mother fucker!
"Well how am I supposed to..."
Live more humbly!
- [Woman] That's it.
- Don't own a house!
Big shot.
That you can't afford!
Rent bitch!
Seriously!
"But how am I supposed to own a home?"
Literally, someone DMed me,
"But Gary, how am I
supposed to own a home?"
I'm like, "You're not motherfucker!
"You haven't fucking figured it out yet!
"You shouldn't do
anything you don't earn."
- Right.
- That's like me saying why am I not
dropping 55 points a game in the NBA?
'Cause I'm not doing it!
The reason you shouldn't
own a home, dickface,
is cause you haven't saved
the money to buy a home,
because that's the next part.
What parents don't fucking understand,
'cause I'm in these conversations.
You see them.
When you're paying for them,
they're not saving because
you pay their rent,
they're buying Yeezys,
Coachella, and fucking drugs.
And when I say drugs, I mean $6 coffee
or fucking cocaine.
I don't give a fuck.
Pick it.
Or the drug of I need to have the freshest
clothes to make pretend
I'm flossing and winning
when I'm not.
Earn your shit.
Stand on your feet.
Be a fucking grown up.
And anything that doesn't do that,
leads to insecurity.
You don't believe you can.
(electronic music)
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- [Woman] There you go.
(laughing)
- [Gary] I'm in rare form.
I feel good, it's Jersey.
(hip hop music)
- [Man] That was awesome.
- That was really good.
- By the way, I think I should only
talk in New Jersey.
- [Man] I agree.
- Right? Fuck it!
(audience cheering)
I'm not sure I wanna talk anywhere else
but fucking New Jersey!
I fucking love you guys!
On some real shit.
I fucking love you guys on some real shit!
On some real shit!
(audience applauding)
Fuck.
(hip hop music)
- Brother, I don't know if there's a more
practical business maneuver than karma.
- I agree with that.
I don't know--
- Look, you know this.
We've run in enough similar circles,
but haven't spent time.
Reputation from people that have actually
spent time with you because, by the way,
there's people who think I'm a snake oil
salesman and I suck, but that's only
'cause they're in a bad
place and they don't know me.
Reputation from people
that actually know you
is the entire currency.
- You know what's funny Gary,
I've been following you
for probably four or five
years and you actually
helped me through a lot
of bullshit that I dealt with,
but you're even better in person.
You're more obviously genuine.
- I understand that.
- I always knew you were genuine, but--
- You know what's really funny?
There was a kid,
Is Zane gone?
- [Max] Yes, he just left.
- Fuck!
(laughing)
How close is he?
How long ago?
- [Max] Like three minutes ago.
- Call him.
Get him back here.
- [Man] Five minutes later.
- Zane, you were...
Wait a minute!
He was in the bathroom!
- [Man] He teleported!
- [Woman] I texted him 9-1-1 come back.
- Zane, were you pooping?
- [Zane] No, I was
going down the elevator.
- Got it.
- [Zane] Hello, what's up?
Nice to meet you.
How's it going?
- Mark.
- [Zane] I'm Zane, nice to meet you, man.
How's it going?
Nice to meet you man, how's it going?
- Zane, Mark was just saying like
it's so interesting to me that you're more
genuine here than I see on video
and I was like it's funny you said that.
Today this kid Zane who works for me,
and I was looking for
you who is a super fan,
engaged in everything.
You've been here what now, two?
- Just about two months.
- What I asked you today,
what was the biggest
thing that surprised you,
what did you say?
- The biggest thing that
surprised me so far,
and it's funny like Gary said,
I'm a huge fan, that's how
I kinda hacked my way here
and it's a crazy story,
but the biggest thing
that's surprised me so far is
genuinely how involved
Gary is on the content.
I know that he was involved,
but before I came here,
I'm sure he's touching a
little bit, reviewing it,
but he's actually
creating all the context.
He's creating the copy.
He's making it and I didn't expect that.
I didn't expect the
deep involvement he has.
- And Mark, what the punch line of that
actually is, this whole game right now,
you on the outside, but
being kind of team Gary--
- Always!
- To right now, more.
Basically here's the punchline.
To Alex, who's sitting out there,
fundamentally, this is
how I judge everybody
and how I judge myself.
Whoever knows the most,
what do they think?
The things I am singularly most proud of
in the world, not a person knows.
Yet everybody thinks I'm a self promoter.
I'm comfortable promoting business.
That's business!
The real humanity, is quiet as fuck.
(harp music)
- So great!
- [Woman] No.
- Awesome.
So just leave it at that, then.
Show me in the video.
Gary Vee.
- [DRock] I want people to sample it.
- Don't worry about what you want,
worry about what I want.
(laughing)
(audience member yells
in foreign language)
(Gary yelling in foreign language)
(laughing)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Listen to me!
I'm fucking mixing up
Russian and English now!
I can't believe you just said that.
I was literally just pee peeing and
(laughing)
and I'm trying to be
cordial amongst the ladies.
And I was like, this is the fucking,
like honestly I gotta take this string off
because it's covering
the numbers sometimes.
I don't like strings in my hoodies.
- [DRock] Ever?
- Ever.
- [Danyah] But you chew on them?
- I do a little bit.
Good point Danyah.
(laughing)
But I don't like chewing on them!
Show me three to five variations
of the starting point of the last video,
which didn't have a sound by the way
that I posted.
Was that my fault?
- [Drock] No, that was my fault.
- I thought so.
That's why I enjoyed that moment.
(laughing)
- I'm that guy.
(hip hop music)